[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 rosa pérez más deuda con
nosotros en esta mesa rosa vamos a abrir
revista de prensa al día de hoy con un
extenso artículo la revista 'time'
dedicada al ex presidente de brasil luiz
inácio lula da silva dice lula segundo
acto un texto de ciara
non gent buenos días exactamente y me
gusta mucho cómo empieza este largo
reportaje y si te parece te leo del
párrafo inicial dice el género que
asignamos a una historia de vida depende
mucho de cómo termina la vida de luis
ignácio lula da silva ya completó varios
arcos dramáticos primero el viaje del
héroe un niño nacido en la pobreza se
muda a la gran ciudad asciende a liderar
un sindicato y luego se convierte en el
presidente más popular de la historia
del brazil moderno luego la tragedia es
acusado en un torpe esquema de
corrupción enviado a prisión y obligado
a observar como sus rivales desmantelan
su legado sin embargo recordemos que la
corte suprema ya anuló las condenas
contra el ex presidente y reconoció que
no había tenido a un juicio justo por lo
que ahora como dice the time el ex
presidente más popular de brasil regresa
del exilio político con la promesa de
salvar la nación y es que recordemos que
de cara a las elecciones de este octubre
las encuestas le atribuyen una potencial
victoria frente al actual presidente
bolsonaro y es que a sus 76 años
lula da silva dice que nunca abandonó
del todo la política no que vive en él y
que tiene una causa que es reformar este
sistema que había creado y que ha sido
desmantelado en los 212 años que ya
lleva fuera del poder en brasil pero
raúl estas piezas que time dedica al
expresidente brasileño se componen por
un lado como decías de este extenso
reportaje pero por otro lado también se
ha publicado la entrevista que
mantuvieron a la periodista y el
expresidente y de esta entrevista se ha
destacado tanto en redes sociales como
en otros medios de comunicación la
opinión de lula da silva respecto a la
guerra de ucrania y es que atribuye
responsabilidades aparte igual es el
esquí y a vladimir putin nos dice que si
bien pues evidentemente putin es el
agresor selenski no se sentó ni antes de
la guerra anilla bajo la invasión
suficientemente tiempo ni
suficientemente en serio en la mesa de
negociación dice que una guerra siempre
es culpa de dos partes de hecho raúl una
cuestión que me ha sorprendido bastante
es que digamos también considera que la
invasión de irak con este ejemplo fue
igual de culpa de george bush que de
sadam husein y bueno raúl básicamente lo
que dice es que es de lenski en lugar de
estar dando discursos en las
televisiones y en los parlamentos de
alrededor de europa debería estar pues
sentado una mesa de negociación junto
con putin y que tanto está guerra pues
también fue digamos responsabilidad de
eeuu y de la unión europea por no haber
asegurado previamente a rusia que
ucrania no iba a entrar en la o bueno
algunos de los puntos de esta larga
entrevista en la que también el
presidente el ex presidente asegura que
si él vuelve a alcanzar la presidencia
de brasil y le propusieran entrar en la
otan diría que no porque él es un hombre
de paz hablando ahora el papel de eeuu
rosa en esta guerra de ucrania un
investigación de new york times revela
que la inteligencia estadounidense está
ayudando ucrania a matar a generales
rusos firmar el texto julian barnes y el
en cooper además de eric schmidt
exactamente no y este ha sido esta ha
sido una revelación del 'new york times'
que como indicaba señala que de los doce
generales rusos muertos en combate en la
guerra de ucrania algunos habrían caído
gracias a la información de inteligencia
que estados unidos proporcionó a kiev
sin embargo las fuentes que no revelan
su identidad en esta pieza del 'new york
times' no especifican cuántos generales
exactamente pues
cayeron gracias a esta información
tampoco especifican qué tipo de
información consiguen es decir como la
consiguen sin embargo a lo largo de esta
guerra ya hemos visto cómo eeuu revelaba
distintas informaciones conseguidas
gracias a satélites tanto comerciales
como clasificados y básicamente lo que
se señala en este texto es que la
inteligencia estadounidense aporta
adquiere las posiciones de las fuerzas
rusas sobre el terreno ucraniano así
como análisis y previsiones de sus
posibles movimientos pero también raúl
señala este texto the new york times que
tras la publicación del artículo que
tuvo lugar ayer por la noche un portavoz
del consejo de seguridad nacional dijo
que la inteligencia no fue proporcionada
a ucrania con la intención de matar a
generales rusos y uno se pregunta
entonces con qué objetivo sin hogar o no
o raúl bueno pues todo un tema peliagudo
porque eeuu evidentemente también va un
poco con pies de plomo para que no se
considere que su intervención busque una
escalada de este conflicto que pues
algunos consideran ya en que está rosa
gracias por toda la información esta
revista de jueves mañana nos vemos con
más pasamos a saludar en nuestra primera
mitad del día